have you ever had a like you know be and
you know we can take this out you ever
been in a place where you had to be
sexual in front of some other people
that were watching I've been involved in
an orgy yeah oh wow I was scared of that
I think I'm never nervous never been in
a threesome I was in a threesome one
time in Indiana and that made me pretty
nervous so you've done it well I've been
in I've been in maybe five or six
threesomes and or do you get the hang of
it or something after a while I think
I've done two of them where I've done a
good where I'm like this is everyone's
sympatico here and we're all getting
along and yeah there's nothing worse
than being the third wheel of the orgy
yeah there yeah yeah yeah where it's
like where it's like your girl just
wanted to shag another girl who she
liked and then you're just sort of off
to the side like that episode and
friends you know I've been that guy yeah
I've been yeah I've been an OG where
where where the other two guys it was
like four girls and three guys oh there
was other guys and yeah yeah but this is
what four guys and build the mofo yeah
four girls three guys I think yeah I
remember the other two guys at one stage
and this is many they know you were Jim
Jefferies or not yeah no what they met
me I organized everything I met everyone
at the comedy club I was good right I
got it all set up but then what happened
was in my early 20s the other the other
guy was a comedy promoter and two of the
girls were his friends and then two of
the other girls were just girls we met
and they were both friends and then the
girl you got to let the girls decide you
know you don't say this is what we're
doing it's got to be you can drop a joke
in or something eventually they've got
to be the decision-makers in the whole
thing yeah and then we're like okay so
then he's the promoter had a mate there
and he was really really good-looking
and the promoter was this really buff
sort of black guy right with a big dong
on him really yeah and he was
good-looking too oh wow and then I was
who everyone was trying to hang out with
because I was funny but then we all got
naked I became like the least popular
person in the room
all right all right and so then like
you're the waiter yeah yeah I'm getting
people drinks and trying to keep the the
atmosphere light changing the thermostat
anyway then eventually but this is this
is this is me my probably not now but I
mean I mean everyone had come a few
times and the girls want to keep going
and I was the only one who could still
get an erection like you've never seen
him work more furiously on the other two
dicks like surely this one still works
and and I just sat in the corner when
you're done with those ones yeah there's
still one open we're working overtime
it's like the Patriot with Mel Gibson
yeah I did um yeah one time I got caught
up with these girls from Indiana but
they didn't know each other right and so
and it was like kind of a hurried
experience because I had to go to the
airport and like yeah that's what we
went everybody strangers yeah it's been
they've been there and I always try to
like introduce these girls like
literally we had like nine minutes to
make it all happen so it was like trying
to have sex and you know kind of
introduce these girls you know do small
talk at the same time like oh so you
know like I was literally having sex I
remember I mean like oh so you know of
you guys you know do you guys go to the
same you know gym or anything you know
like just it was very bizarre and one of
the girls kind of looked a little bit um
like you know like somebody that used to
do weightlifting like in the circus
remember those people that were real
strong kind of he was very barrel
chested yeah polis like she would hold a
bar that had 100 on it you know like she
had a curly moustache a shaved head he's
wearing stripy [ __ ] pajamas good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one